y es el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en directo América de edición
nocturna y para ello me acompaña en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas
noches para ustedes Buenas noches Ángela
Ahora sí vamos a continuar Hoy como ayer
hablando pues del fallecimiento de la
Reina Isabel y los cambios que esto
acarrea que son en la práctica bastante
si se van a demorar bastante tiempo
Jorge Así es Ángela bueno es que
hablamos desde el himno nacional hasta
los billetes pasando por los sellos y
los pasaportes son algunas de las cosas
que van a cambiar tras la muerte de la
reina Isabel segunda y la llegada al
Trono de Carlos III Aunque tomará cierto
tiempo para que el nombre la imagen la
iconografía de la Reina Isabel
desaparezcan de la vida pública pues
vamos a estar conociendo los detalles en
el siguiente reporte
en junio Isabel II apareció en el balcón
del Palacio de buckingham con motivo de
su jubileo la multitud coreó el himno
nacional Dios salve a la reina
[Música]
a partir de ahora la letra del himno
será Dios salve al rey la denominación
de las tradiciones reales también
cambiará ya no se hablará de la guardia
de la reina sino de la guardia del Rey
el rostro de Carlos III empezará a
aparecer en la moneda británica
actualmente circulan 4.500 millones de
billetes con El retrato de la Reina por
un valor total de 80.000 millones de
libras los billetes eran sustituidos en
menos de dos años otros países de la
camonwealth también tendrán que cambiar
su moneda como Nueva Zelanda Canadá
Australia y varias naciones del Caribe
[Aplausos]
todo lo que muestra la insignia la Reina
Isabel II como reina cambiará como los
sellos y los 100.000 buzones del país
pero también en los edificios oficiales
y los uniformes de las fuerzas armadas y
policiales
los pasaportes británicos entregados en
nombre de la reina también tendrán que
ser actualizados muchos otros artículos
de la vida cotidiana británica cambiarán
por primera vez en 70 años incluyendo
tazas platos y recuerdos miles de
productos creados a su imagen también
mostrarán la cara del nuevo Monarca
Jorge el nuevo rey Carlos III se
convierte en monarca en un momento que
es especialmente delicado a nivel
político económico y social es que Reino
Unido está inmerso en una complicada
separación de la Unión Europea la libra
la moneda local se ha desplomado a su
nivel más bajo frente el dólar desde
1985 la inflación ya superó los dos
dígitos y es la más alta en 40 años
mientras que en el plano político el
nacionalismo resuena en Irlanda del
Norte y Escocia el nuevo rey no tiene la
misma popularidad de su madre y desde
ahora será el quien se reúna con la
primera ministra cada semana para
aconsejarla sobre decisiones
trascendentales en momentos de
incertidumbre la nueva primera ministra
list Trust nombrada por la reina el día
martes dos días antes de su muerte
presentó uno de los mayores paquetes
económicos de la historia de Reino Unido
el paquete de ayudas de Trust que
costará más de 100 mil millones de
libras está pensado para proteger a los
hogares Y a las empresas de la subida de
los precios de la energía se destinaron
Aproximadamente 40 mil millones de
libras esterlinas para garantizar que
las empresas energéticas no se queden
sin efectivo en medio de un comercio tan
volátil como el que se vive ahora y es
que los precios de la energía
corresponden a uno de los mayores
problemas allí sin duda alguna en
octubre se espera que el costo de la
energía se duplique con respecto a un
año y que aumenten nuevamente en 2023 la
nueva primera ministra listross limitará
la subida de la factura de la Luz para
todos los hogares durante dos años por
su parte las empresas recibirán ayudas
con precios limitados durante seis meses
los beneficios serán para todos los
habitantes de Inglaterra Escocia y gales
con una asistencia equivalente para
Irlanda del Norte Aunque Reino Unido
adquiere poco gas de Rusia compra su
energía en el mercado internacional
donde los precios sean disparados por la
guerra en Ucrania lo que hace subir los
precios como en el resto de Europa estos
precios tienen su incidencia en la
inflación que ahora mismo significa la
cifra anual en 10,1% en julio Reino
Unido superloto dígitos por primera vez
desde 1982 de acuerdo con la oficina
Nacional de estadísticas uno de los
rubros que más presionó al dato de
inflación fue el de los alimentos esto
subieron de precio en 2,3% entre junio y
Julio de este año es el aumento más alto
a nivel mensual en los últimos 21 años
pues surge un agradecimiento para
ustedes y me despido al final de esta
Crónica porque ya viene el debate